her own phone and her own private
conversations were used so often to
control her that and more shocking
allegations in the latest britney spears
documentary from the new york times have
led britney's legal team to speak out
and take action i just want to be a
happy person here's what we know friday
saw the release of controlling britney
spears the follow-up to this year's
headline making documentary framing
britney spears just because you're in
control doesn't give you the right to
treat people
like property the hour-long special
features brand new claims about just how
much control the conservatorship has
over the pop star's everyday life with
the most shocking allegations coming
from a former employee of the security
firm hired to watch over the singer
they they openly talked about
monitoring her
their their reason for the monitoring
was you know looking for bad influence
looking for potential
you know
illegal activity that might happen that
employee says brittany's father jamie as
well as other members of her team
monitored any communication on the
singer's phone including private phone
calls and messages you would be able to
see all messages
all facetime calls
notes
browser history
photographs there are also claims that
some of brittany's private spaces like
her bedroom were bugged with recording
devices it's unclear if britney was
aware of any of this and whether the
judge presiding over britney's case
approved any of it it's important to
keep in mind mirroring text messages and
recording conversations in a private
place without the consent of both
parties involved can be a violation of
the law
her own phone and her own private
conversations were used so often to
control her i know for a fact that jamie
would come from brittany and say hey
why did you text this person in response
to these claims a lawyer for jaime
issued a statement to the new york times
it said in part quote all of his actions
were well within the parameters of the
authority conferred upon him by the
court i once again want to thank
britney spears for her courage
and for her strength meanwhile
brittany's attorney matthew rosengart
blasted jamie in his response to the
allegations rosengart said quote any
unauthorized intercepting or monitoring
of britney's communications especially
attorney-client communications which are
sacrosynct part of the legal system
would represent a shameful violation of
her privacy rights and a striking
example of the deprivation of her civil
liberties rosengart's statement
continued these actions must be fully
and aggressively investigated we pledged
that after 13 years of the status quo
my firm and i would move aggressively
and expeditiously
to file a petition to suspend
and remove james p spears the reaction
from rosengart follows similar
statements he's made amid the ongoing
court battle that even if jaime is
removed as conservator brittany's new
legal team will continue digging into
her father's conduct throughout the
conservatorship so what does britney
make of these allegations well she may
have given her fans a hint
britney shared this video to instagram
on monday using the caption to call out
miss information from a new documentary
about her but here's the thing she did
not clarify which documentary
controlling britney spears was released
on friday but another documentary this
one titled toxic britney spears's battle
for freedom aired sunday on cnn the
fascination and concern surrounding
brittany has reached fever pitch over
the past few months there's also a
netflix doc set for release this week
for the moment all we know is what
britney wrote in her message quote i
watched a little bit of the last
documentary and i hate to inform you but
a lot of what you heard is not true
these developments come just days ahead
of what could be a pivotal court date on
wednesday a judge is expected to respond
to brittany's request to remove jamie
from the conservatorship as well as her
father's own petition to terminate the
conservatorship altogether e.t will be
on the scene to report on this
potentially game-changing day in court
you